>> Will Sentance: Chúng ta sẽ chuyển sang thế giới tuyệt vời của
không đồng bộ.
Asynchronicity sẽ thay đổi toàn bộ mô hình này.
Tôi sẽ thay đổi nó.
Nó sẽ tăng cường toàn bộ mô hình này.
Toàn bộ mô hình này sẽ tiếp tục tồn tại.
Trên thực tế, lý do chúng tôi cần tăng cường mô hình của mình,
về cơ bản mô hình này sẽ không thể thực hiện được
trong cách chúng ta nghĩ về việc thực hiện các nhiệm vụ mất nhiều thời gian.
Vì vậy, chúng ta hãy chỉ xác nhận.
JavaScript là một luồng, một dòng mã thực thi tại một thời điểm.
Khi tôi bắt đầu chạy nhân với 2, tôi không được phép tiếp tục trong toàn cầu của mình
mã, >> Will Sentance: Để thực thi
tiếp theo nhân với 2 cùng một lúc.
Tôi không được phép, một luồng.
Nhưng đồng thời, tôi cũng không được phép chuyển sang dòng tiếp theo bất kể,
bởi vì, cho đến khi tôi hoàn thành cuộc gọi nhân với 2, bởi vì JavaScript là đồng bộ.
Bây giờ, tất cả những gì có nghĩa là tôi đi từ trên xuống dưới.
Tôi không bao giờ chuyển sang dòng tiếp theo, cho đến khi tôi hoàn thành dòng trước.
Tôi không bao giờ chuyển sang dòng tiếp theo.
Nếu bạn thấy một đầu mối chức năng, tôi phải quay lại khỏi nó.
Tôi phải hoàn thành việc thực thi nó trước khi tôi nhấn dòng tiếp theo.
Chà, điều này ám chỉ một vấn đề lớn.
Điều gì sẽ xảy ra nếu tôi nhân với hai cuộc gọi trong đó tôi gọi đến một máy chủ,
sẽ mất 300 mili giây?
Tôi không được phép chuyển từ dòng đó để chạy bất kỳ
nhiều JavaScript hơn cho đến khi điều đó trở lại.
Điều gì xảy ra nếu tôi nhấp vào xem thêm các tweet,
nó chạy mã JavaScript cho biết, hãy nhận nhiều tweet hơn.
Sẽ mất 300 hoặc 200 mili giây trước khi các tweet quay trở lại,
nhưng trong thời gian chờ đợi, tôi đang nhấn thích trên một tweet,
sẽ chạy nhiều mã JavaScript hơn để chuyển nó sang màu hồng và
để tăng số lượt thích trên tweet đó ở trạng thái của tôi, vào bộ nhớ của tôi.
Điều đó không thể xảy ra, tôi sẽ ngồi đó nhấp chuột vì tôi vẫn còn bận chờ đợi
dòng nói rằng hãy nhận nhiều tweet hơn.
Bởi vì tôi phải đợi cho đến khi nó trả lại các tweet, phải, trước khi tôi có thể
chuyển sang dòng tiếp theo của tôi nói rằng, tô màu trái tim màu hồng, vì tôi đã nhấp vào nút.
Đây sẽ là một vấn đề sâu sắc.
Điều gì sẽ xảy ra nếu chúng ta muốn đợi một thời gian trước khi chúng ta thực sự có thể sử dụng hoặc sở hữu các bit mã.
Chúng tôi muốn đợi cho đến khi dữ liệu của chúng tôi quay trở lại từ Twitter,
trước khi chúng tôi có thể hiển thị và chạy chức năng, hãy hiển thị dữ liệu đó.
>> Will Sentance: Có lẽ chúng ta cần lấy thêm dữ liệu từ API, hoặc
thậm chí là một bộ đếm thời gian để hoàn thành và sau đó chúng tôi muốn chạy một số mã.
Chúng tôi có một câu hỏi hóc búa.
Sự căng thẳng giữa việc muốn trì hoãn một số mã đang chạy, bởi vì chúng tôi đang chờ đợi
dữ liệu quay lại, vì vậy chúng tôi muốn dòng mã tiếp theo hiển thị các tweet đó.
Chúng tôi muốn thêm dữ liệu để thực sự quay trở lại.
Nhưng chúng tôi biết cách chặn luồng đơn của mình tiếp tục chạy mã.
Sẽ có một câu hỏi hóc búa.
Đó sẽ là bản chất tại sao chúng ta phải giới thiệu trong JavaScript
một mô hình bổ sung hoàn toàn cho thế giới đồng bộ đẹp đẽ của chúng ta.
Điều này, chỉ ba phần này của JavaScript là không đủ.
Điều đặc biệt thú vị là tính không đồng bộ trong Java,
thế giới không đồng bộ của Java là một điều thú vị.
Tôi yêu công cụ JavaScript đơn giản thuần túy của chúng tôi, nhưng mọi thứ chúng tôi yêu thích
phát triển ứng dụng web không diễn ra trong JavaScript thuần túy.
JavaScript thuần túy không biết cách nói chuyện với Internet.
Đó không phải là một tính năng của JavaScript để nói chuyện với Internet.
Thay vào đó, tất cả các tính năng đó nằm ngoài JavaScript.
Họ đang ngồi ngoài JavaScript ở đâu?
Tên bạn là gì?
>> Alec: Alec.
>> Will Sentance: Alec, họ đang ngồi ở đâu?
Những tính năng không phải của JavaScript nằm ở đâu,
họ đang làm những việc như nói chuyện với Internet.
Họ ở đâu?
>> Alec: API? >> Will Sentance: Hay không tính năng của
JavaScript, xin lỗi.
Đâu là các tính năng nói với Internet mà Java nên sử dụng?
Vâng, điều đó có nghĩa là gì?
>> Alec: Tôi không biết, các dịch vụ web yên tĩnh và.
>> Will Sentance: Michelle, đâu là những tính năng, ví dụ,
có thể nói chuyện với Internet?
>> Người nói 3: Có trong trình duyệt [CROSSTALK] không?
>> Will Sentance: Họ đang ở trong trình duyệt.
Trình duyệt có vô số tính năng mà chúng tôi trong JavaScript có quyền truy cập.
Chúng tôi viết mã JavaScript về cơ bản là một mặt tiền,
chúng ta sẽ thấy những thứ này, mặt tiền của chúng ta, cho một loạt các tính năng
không có trong JavaScript mà thay vào đó là trong trình duyệt web.
Đó là những gì chúng ta sẽ dành phần lớn thời gian sáng nay để làm.
Là viết mã JavaScript giao diện API.
Vì vậy, Alex đúng.
Interfaces, I in API là viết tắt của giao diện.
Điều đó tương tác với những thứ bên ngoài JavaScript.
Được rồi, chúng tôi cần một loạt các tính năng hoàn toàn mới trong JavaScript và
bên ngoài Javascript để hiểu cách hoạt động của nó.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi bắt đầu.
Đây là giải pháp đầu tiên của chúng tôi.
Và tôi sẽ nói trước với bạn rằng điều đó về cơ bản là không thể hiểu được.
Nhưng đây là giải pháp đầu tiên của chúng tôi về cách thực hiện và thực hiện một nhiệm vụ sẽ thực hiện
một thời gian dài như nói chuyện với Twitter và nhận lại các tweet của chúng tôi.
Và tuy nhiên, có thể tiếp tục chạy mã, nhưng
biết dữ liệu đó ở đâu khi nó quay trở lại.
Giải pháp đầu tiên ở đây sẽ không thể thực hiện được, nhưng
Tuy nhiên, nó sẽ khá trực quan, nhưng hoàn toàn không thể hiểu được.
Được rồi.
Dòng 1 và nhân tiện,
cho đến nay chúng tôi vẫn thấy những thứ rất giống với những phần cứng đầu tiên,
nhưng chúng ta cần tìm hiểu những nền tảng này để hiểu được những điều khó khăn hơn sắp tới.
Được rồi, dòng 1, Abdie?
>> Abdi: Chà, chúng tôi đang khai báo hiển thị trong môi trường biến của chúng tôi.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, nói rất hay, Abdie.
Hiển thị được khai báo, xuất sắc.
Dòng mã tiếp theo, Alec?
Thực hiện bên tay trái trước.
>> Abdi: Chúng tôi đang khai báo dữ liệu từ API.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, và những gì nó sẽ được chỉ định?
>> Abdi: Hàm fetchAndWait.
>> Will Sentance: Không, chúng tôi không bao giờ gán chức năng.
Nếu chúng ta không có dấu ngoặc ở đó, nó sẽ nói tốt, cái gì đang tìm nạpAndWait?
Và nó sẽ gán nó cho cái đó, bất kể nó là gì.
Nhưng JavaScript không làm điều đó ở phía bên phải.
Và những gì một người lái xe luôn bảo tôi phải làm, Blessing?
>> Diễn giả 3: Giải mã một hàm.
>> Will Sentance: Giải mã.
Bên tay phải ở đây là một lệnh.
Đó là công việc chưa hoàn thành.
Vì vậy, hãy thực sự rõ ràng với bản thân không có cách nào được chỉ định.
API dữ liệu không quan tâm đến fetchAndWait.
Mối quan tâm duy nhất của nó là bất cứ thứ gì được trả lại từ fetchAndWait,
mà chúng tôi hy vọng sẽ là tweet của chúng tôi.
Được rồi, vì vậy fetchAndWait ở đây là một hàm tạo sẵn, nhưng chúng ta hãy xem nó làm gì.
Vì vậy, dữ liệu từ API sẽ trở thành
của fetchAndWait đến URL Twitter của chúng tôi.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi hy vọng nó sẽ trả lại một tweet tốt đẹp cho chúng tôi.
Đó là những gì chúng tôi đang hy vọng.
Vì vậy, hãy bắt đầu theo dõi thời gian của chúng ta đang trôi qua.
Chúng tôi đang ở khoảng một phần nghìn giây ở đây.
Giả sử điều này ở đây mất 200 mili giây để hoàn thành.
>> Will Sentance: 200 mili giây
sau, >> Will Sentance: Cuối cùng của chúng tôi
dữ liệu quay trở lại.
Có thể là 300 mili giây, có thể là nửa giây.
Chúng tôi thậm chí không biết.
Trong thời gian đó, chúng tôi có được phép tiếp tục và chạy bất kỳ mã JavaScript nào nữa không?
Hoàn toàn không, chúng tôi không được phép đi tiếp.
Chúng tôi bị chặn vì chuỗi JavaScript của chúng tôi là đồng bộ.
Có công việc chúng tôi vẫn đang làm ở phía bên phải đây.
Chúng tôi không được phép chuyển sang dòng tiếp theo, và
chúng tôi sẽ không muốn vì dòng tiếp theo cho biết, hãy hiển thị dữ liệu API của bạn.
Vì vậy, tốt hơn chúng ta nên lấy lại dữ liệu đó nếu chúng ta sẽ hiển thị nó.
Đây là giải pháp 1 của chúng tôi.
Hãy rõ ràng, đây không phải là giải pháp đúng, nhưng đây là một giải pháp.
Vậy là 200 mili giây trôi qua và yêu cầu của chúng tôi đối với Twitter trả về,
chúng ta hãy nói, rất hay, nó trả về dữ liệu của chúng ta và nó là
nó là một Tweet duy nhất và nó thậm chí không quay lại dưới dạng một đối tượng,
tất nhiên chúng trở lại với tư cách là đối tượng.
Nhưng chỉ là một Tweet cao.
Và chúng ta sẽ cất cao, ở đâu, Michelle?
>> Michelle: Trong dữ liệu từ API.
>> Will Sentance: Trong dữ liệu từ API.
Tôi xin lỗi vì có vẻ như tôi đang sửa tất cả cách phát âm của bạn.
Đã cập nhật dữ liệu, nhưng tôi thì không.
Tôi chấp nhận những phát âm sai của bạn.
Được chứ.
Làm tốt tất cả các bạn vì tham nhũng, không, không tham nhũng.
>> Will Sentance: Tốt.
Tùy chỉnh một ngôn ngữ đẹp.
Được rồi.
Được rồi, tốt.
Vì vậy, API dữ liệu có cao, chuỗi cao được lưu trữ trong đó.
200 mili giây sau đó, trong thời gian đó không thể chạy thêm mã JavaScript nào nữa.
Điều này là hoàn toàn tai hại.
Dù sao đi nữa, bây giờ chúng ta đã đạt được dòng tiếp theo, đó là ai mà tôi vẫn chưa gọi?
Sonny, dòng mã tiếp theo của chúng ta cần làm gì?
>> Sonny: Để vượt qua API dữ liệu để hiển thị càng cao.
>> Will Sentance: Đúng. Vì vậy, chúng tôi chuyển sang nhớ lại màn hình
hàm với đối số của chúng tôi là giá trị của dữ liệu từ API,
mọi thứ trong Java là chúng tôi sẽ đánh giá ngay lập tức,
dữ liệu từ API ở đây là một chuỗi cao ', chúng tôi đưa thẳng vào.
Và chúng tôi tạo bằng cách sử dụng ngữ cảnh để chạy nó ở nơi trong bộ nhớ, điều này thực sự rõ ràng
ở đây, trong dữ liệu bộ nhớ, dữ liệu tham số được đặt thành đối số cao.
Và vì vậy chúng tôi sẽ đăng nhập vào bảng điều khiển của mình.
Vào khoảng 201 mili giây, chúng ta sẽ đạt mức cao.
Được chứ.
Và bây giờ cuối cùng, chúng ta sẽ đánh dòng nào tiếp theo?
Quý ông, bạn tên gì?
>> Ben: Ben >> Will Sentance: Ben.
Xin lỗi, Ben.
>> Ben: Chúng tôi sẽ ghi lại cho tôi sau.
>> Will Sentance: Tôi sau này sẽ được đăng nhập tại
khoảng thời gian sau đó của năm 202
mili giây, tôi sau đó được ghi lại.
>> Will Sentance: Hãy giơ tay nếu bạn là một fan hâm mộ lớn của giải pháp này.
Tôi là một fan hâm mộ lớn của điều này.
Không, tôi không bận tâm về giải pháp.
Đây là lý do tại sao tôi không bận tâm về giải pháp, nó có tính trực quan sâu sắc.
Chúng tôi có ba mục tiêu, ba mục tiêu.
Có thể thực hiện các tác vụ mất nhiều thời gian, tác vụ chậm,
như lấy dữ liệu từ Twitter.
Chúng tôi phải có khả năng làm điều đó.
Nếu không, ứng dụng web của chúng tôi rất, rất nhàm chán.
Tốt nhất chúng ta có thể làm trò chơi treo cổ,
một trò chơi treo cổ rất hay trong dòng lệnh, nhưng đó là điều tốt nhất chúng tôi có thể làm.
Nhưng chúng tôi muốn có thể tiếp tục chạy mã JavaScript của mình trong thời gian chờ đợi.
Chúng tôi không thể làm điều đó ở đây.
Hãy xem này, trong thời gian chờ đợi, mã JavaScript Node được phép chạy cho
200 mili giây.
Khi nhiệm vụ chậm của chúng tôi hoàn thành mặc dù chúng tôi sẽ có thể chạy chức năng
biết nhiệm vụ đã hoàn thành và dữ liệu đã sẵn sàng.
Đó là một chút khó khăn.
Vì vậy, hóa ra, mọi giải pháp khác mà chúng tôi có, đó là một chút khó khăn.
Trong giải pháp này, không một chút khó khăn.
Giải pháp này, thật dễ dàng.
Tôi có thể thấy nơi dữ liệu của mình được đồng bộ theo thứ tự, trong bộ nhớ.
Tôi không gặp vấn đề gì khi chức năng hiển thị của tôi sẽ chạy.
Nó sẽ không chạy theo đúng nghĩa đen trong chuỗi đơn của tôi cho đến khi tôi lấy lại dữ liệu của mình.
Tôi chỉ giao dịch trong thế giới đồng bộ ở đây, theo thứ tự, từ trên xuống dưới.
Đó là lý do tại sao chúng tôi yêu thích mô hình chuỗi đơn JavaScript.
Đó là tầm nhìn đằng sau nó, nó có khả năng dự đoán cao không và
dễ dàng làm việc với một nhà phát triển.
Nhưng rõ ràng, nó về cơ bản là không thể hiểu được.
Chặn chuỗi JavaScript đơn của chúng tôi chạy bất kỳ mã nào khác
trong khi nhiệm vụ này hoàn thành.
Lợi ích, nó chắc chắn dễ dàng để lý luận, nhưng nó không thể giải thích được.